[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
in allen guten abend angst ist kein
guter ratgeber aber die realität einfach
ausblenden können wir eben auch nicht
und die realität sieht leider so aus
dass russlands führung nicht mehr
ausschließt auch atomwaffen einzusetzen
und seit wochen droht mit einem krieg in
neuer dimension
wie immer ist sowas natürlich auch ein
krieg der worte angst schüren ist auch
eine waffe und mit diesem personal kennt
sich wladimir putin besonders gut aus
andererseits steht schlicht zu viel auf
dem spiel um es eben mal ab zu tun als
alles nur bluff zumindest bereiten sich
der us-präsident und die nato staaten
also auch deutschland jetzt konkret vor
auf einen ernstfall über den wir
eigentlich höchstens noch als
theoretische möglichkeit reden wollten
und nie mehr als konkretes szenario
heute ist tag der krisengipfel in
brüssel
erste antwort auf die krise heute
symbolbilder schulterschluss mit joe
biden gegen putin so die botschaft aus
der nato inhaltlich aber steht vor allem
eine frage im raum
wir haben ja vor chemiewaffen gewarnt
haben sie da bestimmte
geheimdienstinformationen
ich kann das nicht beantworten ich kann
ihnen keine geheimdienstinformationen
geben und zweitens wir würden auf einen
angriff antworten und zwar mit genau den
gleichen mitteln
us medien spekulieren der ausbleibende
kriegs erfolg könnte putin zu neuen
waffen greifen lassen sowie im syrien
krieg 2018 giftgas angriffe auf
zivilisten in haft natürlich müssen wir
alles in betracht ziehen was russland
tun könnte die wir müssen vorbereitet
sein die sagen ja auch wir könnten
chemie waffen einsetzen das ist absolute
rechnung
wir haben pläne aber ich werde heute
keine rote linie in dieser frage ziehen
fakt ist aber auch der oberbefehlshaber
der nato in europa hat kleinere
einheiten in abc alarmbereitschaft
versetzt zudem wird schutzausrüstung in
die ukraine liefert generalsekretär
stoltenberg warnt da sich chemische
kampfstoffe am ende auch auf nato gebiet
ausbreiten könnten ende hughes und jeder
gebrauch von chemiewaffen würde den
konflikt fundamental verändern das hätte
weitreichende und ernsthafte konsequent
präsident sie lenski erwähnt das thema
heute nicht aber einmal mehr nimmt er
die nato in die pflicht
die nato muss noch zeigen was sie tut um
menschen zu retten sie muss beweisen
dass sie das mächtigste militärbündnis
der welt ist die welt wartet auf euch
die ukraine wartet
mehr waffen nach kiew das leistet die
nato zudem werden vier neue gefechts
verbände an der nato ostflanke
stationiert
nachdem nato ein kurzer g7-gipfel
austausch mit dem japanischen
premierminister hier ist er das bild die
botschaft einheit der staatschefs gegen
putin am späten nachmittag zieht die
karawane weiter dritter gipfel des tages
bei der europäischen union es geht um
ein mögliches energie embargo gegen
russland nicht nur die deutschen zögern
das heißt die österreichische position
ganz klar es wird mit uns kein gas
über der russischen föderation geben das
ist derzeit nicht realistisch unklar ist
ob putin überhaupt weiter energie
liefert er will jetzt rubel für öl und
gas die europäer sensation nicht bereit
das was wir bisher erfahren haben läuft
darauf hinaus dass es überall feste
verträge gibt in der die währungen der
bezahlt wird auch teil des vertrags ist
und das ist ja etwas was dann auch gilt
und dann steht meistens euro oder dollar
ein us präsident auf einem eu-gipfel das
hat es 20 jahre lang nicht gegeben der
krieg zwingt beide seiten zu
außenpolitischer stärke und zur einheit
beitrag von ina baltes war das bringen
wir unsere usa und russland
korrespondenten jetzt mit dazu in die
sendung zunächst zu el mati wissen
aktuell in brüssel immer der us
präsident hat sich ja bislang betont
zurückgehalten bloß nicht extra feuer
machen wenn die welt jetzt spürt man in
seiner wortwahl und auch beim nato-chef
eine neue dringlichkeit und alarmiert
hat woran liegt das
ja ich glaube die beiden steht unter
druck er will ja eine moralische
außenpolitik das hat er nach amtsantritt
vor einem jahr angekündigt und die villa
machen mit hilfe von bündnissen in denen
man sich einig ist und nun fragen sich
immer mehr menschen auch in den usa
angesichts der bilder aus der ukraine
wie glaubwürdig ist eine moralische
außenpolitik wenn sie zulässt das ganze
städte zerstört werden dass eben
menschen massakriert werden regelrecht
und deswegen will joe biden zwei dinge
tun das eine ist die ukraine noch viel
mehr unterstützen mit waffenlieferungen
da werden wir einige details in den
nächsten tagen gar nicht erfahren
waffensysteme die da weitergegeben
werden und das andere ist eben den spieß
herumzudrehen autoritäre systeme nutzen
eben oft wirtschaftliche abhängigkeiten
um andere staaten zu erpressen oder
bündnisse zu spalten und joe biden will
beweisen dass er diese wirtschaftlichen
abhängigkeiten auch nutzen kann um diese
autoritären regime in die knie zu
zwingen aber das funktioniert mit
absoluter einigkeit und geschlossenheit
und das sollte das signal heute sein und
dann wir gerade gesehen die nato
aktiviert jetzt die sogenannte abwehr
gegen einen möglichen atomaren angriff
was heißt das genau
ja das bedeutet dass alle nato einheiten
an der ostflanke entsprechende spur
geräte bekommen dass sie ausgestattet
werden mit schutzausrüstung das ist der
erste punkt der zweite ist dass alle
aufklärungskapazitäten der nato allen
voran der usa genutzt werden um zu
entdecken wenn irgendwelche
vorbereitungen im gange sind für den
einsatz von abc-waffen ganz besonders
wenn beispielsweise nukleare gefäß
sprengköpfe auf die raketen montiert
werden wenn die mobilen abschuss systeme
im land verteilt werden das will man
entdecken und das dritte ist etwas
darüber werden wir keine einzelheiten
erfahren im weißen haus hat ein team
eine task force die so das sogenannte
tiger-team szenarien durchgespielt was
könnte passieren wie könnte man
antworten darüber haben die
bündnispartner auch im engsten kreise
beraten aber streng geheim weil wenn
irgendetwas von möglichen antworten
heraus sichert könnte das auch eine
bedienungsanleitung für putin sagen wie
wir wer gehen kann
christian in moskau wir würden ja gerne
in putins kopf rein schauen wir können
das nicht stattdessen wird jedes detail
in diesen tagen genau analysiert und es
gibt tatsächlich einige merkwürdigkeiten
der russische verteidigungsminister war
seit fast zwei wochen nicht mehr in der
öffentlichkeit gesehen worden wo ist
sergej schoigu
ja das fragen sich nicht nur viele hier
in russland sondern auf der ganzen welt
zum beispiel sagen die amerikaner
sie hätten versucht jetzt schon seit
über einer woche schoigu ans telefon zu
bekommen und das würde nicht klappen und
man muss wissen diese militärischen
kontakte die es noch gibt die sind sehr
wichtig um eine mögliche eskalation dann
doch im direkten kontakt zu verhindern
der kreml sprecher per software wurde
heute auch nach stunden nach schicksal
befragt und presskopf hat es dann eher
abgetan gesagt na ja der mann habe viel
zu tun wegen der ukraine und am montag
wurde dann auch noch ein video
veröffentlicht dass wladimir putin zeigt
in einer video-konferenz mit dem
sicherheitsrat wo ja auch immer dabei
ist dann sieht man auf den bildern oben
links im monitor sieht man schoigu das
soll zeigen dass an dem treffen auch
teilgenommen hat und dann springt das
bild aber um wird plötzlich schwarz und
es sieht so aus als würde vielleicht
gespült werden auf jeden fall stimmt
irgendwas mit dem bild nicht und das
lässt natürlich die spekulationen hier
hoch laufen das streugut vielleicht doch
nicht daran teilgenommen hat dass das
video möglicherweise
manipuliert ist und die spekulationen
schießen ins kraut über den
gesundheitszustand von bruder dass er
möglicherweise bei putin in ungnade
gefallen ist also wenn dieses video
heute zeigen sollte dass alles in
ordnung ist dann war es schlecht gemacht
wenn es dafür sorgen soll weiter die
welt im ungewissen zu lassen dann hat es
funktioniert
herzlichen dank elmer hat sie lange
christian jenseits aller kreml logischen
deutungen wird eins immer klarer es
läuft nicht nach plan für wladimir putin
militärexperten sind erstaunt über die
hohe zahl an opfern unter russland
soldaten das offenbar bereits fünf
hochrangige generäle gefallen sind ein
viertel so schätzungen aller kommandeure
in der ukraine
und darüber wie viele fahrzeuge die
russen verloren haben heute dann dazu
diese bilder feuer am hafen von barry
also schon mehr ein ukrainischer hafen
in russischer hand wo schweres gerät und
nachschub an kommen für die
invasionsarmee offenbar steht mindestens
ein russisches kriegsschiff in flammen
wird immer wieder von explosionen
erschüttert die ukraine behauptet sie
habe der russischen armee damit schwere
verluste zugefügt
michael renz jetzt über putins strategie
und was aus ihr wurde
straßenkampf in mariupol haus für haus
müssen die russischen soldaten erobern
überall können verteidiger lauern
verlustreiches ringen um ruinen
von anfang an läuft russlands invasion
nicht rund bilder aus den ersten tagen
nach dem überfall zerstörte russische
fahrzeuge
auffällig vor allem leichter aufklärer
werden damals opfer der ukrainischen
abwehren bilder von zerstörten schweren
panzern sieht man da noch eher selten
anders als erwartet glaubt moskau das
leichte einheiten ausreichend den
nachbarn zu erobern ein fataler fehler
und teil einer falschen strategie des
russischen oberkommandos dass die
ukraine aus mehreren richtungen
gleichzeitig angreift die ukraine sollen
keine chance haben ihre verteidigung zu
konzentrieren doch gleichzeitig wird
schnell klar der kreml hat sich
verkalkuliert für diese aufgabe sind es
zu wenige truppen und zu wenig material
der vormarsch verläuft nicht wie geplant
putins generalstab denkt um schickt nach
den ersten misserfolgen mehr schwere
panzer ins gefecht doch die haben neben
den verteidigern noch einen weiteren
gegner das wetter der frühling kommt in
osteuropa die gefrorenen böden town auf
felder und wiesen verwandeln sich in
much wüsten der albtraum jedes
panzerfahrer jetzt können sie ihre
größte trumpfkarte die kombination aus
feuerkraft und geschwindigkeit nicht
ausspielen müssen sich an befestigte
straßen und wege klammern stehen im stau
und werden so zum leichten ziel der
ukraine mit panzerabwehrwaffen und
artillerie verwandeln sie auf die
vormals straßen in todeszonen
besonders auf tanker und laster mit
nachschub und munition haben sie es
abgesehen wenn die nicht mehr ankommen
bleiben die russischen panzer
automatisch stehen
längst sind die aufgegebenen
stahlkolosse am abschleppseil
ukrainische bauern zum synonym für
russlands probleme mit dem nachschub
geworden es fehlt an allem sogar
proviant ist oft mangelware bilder von
überwachungskameras zeigen russische
soldaten beim plündern von supermärkten
schlecht für die ohnehin angeknackste
kampfmoral der truppe deren verluste
täglich steigen die verteidiger nehmen
sie mit modernen abwehrwaffen unter
feuer bis zu 500 dieser leichten raketen
werden pro tag verschossen berichten
westliche geheimdienste auch am himmel
sind die invasoren nicht sicher
esslinger flugabwehrsysteme machen ihnen
das leben schwer mehr als 41.000 moderne
waffen hat der westen bisher geliefert
und sie machen einen unterschied darüber
sind sich experten einig
besonders wenn sie in die hände
entschlossener kämpfer gelangen tausende
ukraine melden sich jetzt zu den waffen
damit hat man in moskau nicht gerechnet
offenbar hat putin seine gegner
unterschätzt ein kapitaler fehler wie
sich jetzt herausstellt
nach vier wochen krieg zeigen
satellitenbilder erstaunliches die
angreifer graben sich einstellungs stadt
blitzkrieg moskaus strategie vom
schnellen sieg ist gescheitert
das mag sich jetzt erstmal paradox
anhören aber je schlechter es für
wladimir putin in der ukraine läuft
desto größer wird die befürchtung im
westen er könnte mit dem rücken an der
wand zur chemischen waffen greifen zu
biologischen oder gar atomaren ein thema
ich weiß das ganz große sorgen auslöst
besonders noch mal bei den
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern die die
letzten katastrophalen krieg miterleben
mussten wir kommen an dem thema aber
nicht mehr vorbei und historische
perspektive gibt immer halt sönke
neitzel von der uni potsdam ist
deutschlands einziger professor für
militärgeschichte guten abend herr
professor schon gute nannte sie was wo
stehen wir denn aktuell wenn sie das mal
vergleichen mit den hochzeiten des
kalten kriegs mit der kubakrise etwa
ja ich glaube dass die die geschichte
die krise jetzt
unberechenbarer ist im vergleich zum
kalten krieg im kalten krieg hatten wir
zwar ein riesiges waffenarsenal vielmehr
atomsprengköpfe noch so was wir die kuba
krise aber das zeigt die historische
forschung eigentlich war die welt
vergleichsweise sicher trotz der vielen
waffen denn ein mann wie kunststoff
anmahnen wie berechnet war berechenbar
ähnlich wie kennedy oder wie ronald
reagan also verrückt sie manchmal uns
erscheinen mögen heute sie waren
berechenbar und einen kunststoff
anbrechenden selber den zweiten
weltkrieg erlebt und sie hatten wie wir
heute wissen kein interesse daran die
welt in einen nuklearkrieg zu stürzen
und diese berechenbarkeit darauf würde
ich jetzt abzielen die haben wir
natürlich heute über putin nicht wir
können seine logik sehr schwer
einschätzen es gibt die einen sagen es
sei rational die anderen wie sie eben an
ihrer moderation angedeutet haben sagen
im notfall wird er auch abc waffen
einsetzen aber diese berechenbarkeit
haben wir heute nicht und deswegen ist
es glaube ich im vergleich zum kalten
krieg heute gefährlicher wenn putin so
viel unberechenbarer ist was sind denn
die szenarien die er jetzt im sinn haben
könnte wenn er nicht ausschließt auch
atome anzugreifen
ja auch das da würde ich unterstreichen
was sie gesagt haben in der anmoderation
wenn putin ist nicht schafft der ukraine
militärisch seinen willen aufzudrücken
und danach sieht es zurzeit betone
zurzeit aus das ist eher die frage er
hat die eskalation dominanz und wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass er dann
bereit ist ein gang zuzulegen dass er
dann bereit ist auch chemie waffen
einzusetzen um zum beispiel die
bevölkerung aus mario pohl zur flucht zu
treiben um ein exempel zu statuieren und
es er vielleicht auch bereit ist mit
atom schlägen zu drohen zum beispiel
gegen polen um zu sagen wenn der westen
die waffenlieferung nicht einstellt wird
mit einem nuklear schlag drohen das ist
zur zeit noch nicht an würden wir sagen
das ist liegt zurzeit noch nicht auf dem
tisch aber wir können es auf keinen fall
ausschließen wie reagieren das ist ja
die große frage die heute hinter
verschlossenen türen auch in brüssel
diskutiert wurde wir haben es gehört der
us präsident hat das sogenannte tiger
team in seinem nationalen sicherheitsrat
aktiviert dass ihm diverse options-
möglichkeiten vorlegen soll
sind die dann quasi in stein gemeißelt
dass der westen also eine eine reaktion
bereits vorgibt oder ist das eine
falsche entscheidung die dann auch
spontan gefällt wird also ich glaube
dieses tiger team bereitet szenarien vor
dass man zumindest mal es durchdacht hat
dass man sich auch darauf vorbereitet
dass man auch reagieren kann dass man
auch entsprechende
aufklärungsmöglichkeiten in bereitschaft
hat usw aber ich glaube solche
entscheidungen werden letztlich vom
amerikanischen präsidenten getroffen wir
wissen es natürlich nicht so einfach hat
es ja noch nie gegeben aber die
historische forschung zeigt vom kalten
krieg das ist natürlich eine abstimmung
innerhalb der nato gab es gab einem
nuklear planning group aber letztlich
gehen wir jetzt drucker davon aus dass
er ist immer der amerikanische präsident
gewesen wäre der letztlich selber abwägt
was auch sein eigenes land anbetrifft
und ob der amerikanische präsident auch
gewählt ist einen nuklearen angriff auf
die usa zu riskieren also daran werden
wir da haben wir keinen einblick ich war
leider nicht team dieses dieses teams
aber wir müssen davon ausgehen dass
jenseits von dem was auf gipfeln wie
jetzt eben gesagt wurde die amerikaner
aus eigeninteressen natürlich handeln
werden und die große frage ist was
während die amerikaner tun wo ziehen sie
intern ihre roten linien sind sie bereit
bei einem nuklearwaffen einsatz sofort
zurückzuschlagen welches die nach den
spielen sie dadurch und da haben wir
keinen einblick und da sind wir
letztlich in den händen des
amerikanischen präsidenten
herr professor neitzel das ist ja ein
gespräch das man eigentlich am liebsten
gar nicht führen möchte sie nicht ich
nichts habe ich vorhin schon gesagt
jetzt müssen wir eine sache sagen die
vielleicht so ein bisschen hoffnung gibt
denn die nato sieht aktuell keine
anzeichen dass russland tatsächlich ganz
konkrete vorbereitungen treffen würde
für so einen atomwaffen einsatz heißt
dass wir würden das in jedem fall mit
bekommen wir haben das sehr sehr gut
überwacht
nach allen erfahrungen die wir haben aus
dem kalten krieg im weiß die nato sehr
genau bescheid was im nuklearen bereich
in russland passiert und als putin kurz
nach dem beginn des angriffskrieges
verkündet hat er würde die
einsatzbereitschaft der nuklear
streitkräfte erhöhen hat die nato nichts
dergleichen festgestellt das war also
zunächst eine verbale drohung keine
reale bedrohung und ich glaube was jetzt
gefragt ist ist dass wir nicht in panik
verfallen aber dass wir putin auf der
anderen seite auch nicht unterschätzen
und ja meine empfehlung ist zeitenwende
heißt eben auch zu lernen mit der
nuklearen bedrohung wieder leben zu
lernen wir haben das verlernt nach 1990
wir haben auch nukleare bedrohung aus
dem gebiet kaliningrad nicht ernst
genommen und zeitenwende heißt wir
müssen mit diesem szenario wieder lernen
zu leben wie immer spannend von ihnen
zuhören herzlichen dank professor von
der uni potsdam heute schon mal sehr
gerne
und angesichts der bedrohungslage in
europa fordert die chefin des roten
kreuzes gerda hasselfeldt eine
zeitenwende beim katastrophenschutz in
deutschland fragen an sie nachher im
heute journal update jetzt
erstmal bei uns die bemühungen der
weltgemeinschaft eine lösung zu finden
damit beginnst du hanna und die welt hat
sich dabei heute ziemlich geschlossen
gezeigt großer mehrheit hat die
un-vollversammlung eine weitere
resolution gegen den russischen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine angenommen
gefordert wird eine sofortige waffenruhe
insbesondere das ende aller angriffe auf
zivilpersonen und zivile objekte bei der
abstimmung in new york notierten 140
länder für die resolution 38 enthielten
sich und nur fünf länder stimmten
dagegen
neben russland waren dass belarus syrien
eritrea und nordkorea
wir bleiben bei nordkorea bereits
mehrfach hat das land in diesem jahr mit
raketentests für schlagzeilen gesorgt
nun soll pjöngjang laut südkorea und
japan eine atomwaffenfähige
interkontinentalrakete
abgefeuert haben solche raketen haben
eine reichweite von mehr als 5500
kilometern nach angaben tokios landete
das geschoss in japanischen
hoheitsgewässern der letzte test einer
solchen rakete war im jahr 2017
und wir blicken auf die krone
infektionen denn zum ersten mal seit
pandemie beginn liegt die zahl der
neuinfizierten über 300.000 das rk ii
registrierte 318
1387 fälle innerhalb eines tages das
sind etwa
23.500 mehr als vor einer woche
300 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage incidents ist auf
1.752 gestiegen
deutlich höher liegt die inzidenz in
mecklenburg vorpommern mit
22,5 ist die so hoch wie in keinem
anderen bundesland
nun hat der landtag in schwerin die
bisherigen corona schutzmaßnahmen
verlängert spd grüne und linke haben
beschlossen das unter anderem die masken
pflicht im innenbereich bis zum 27 april
bestehen bleiben soll mehrere kliniken
in mecklenburg vorpommern sind bereits
am limit ist zu einem drittel des
personals hält corona bedingt aus
der bundeskanzler kam ein bisschen zu
spät zum mammut gipfeltag in brüssel
weil er zu hause in berlin noch eine
elfstündige nachtsitzung mit der ampel
koalition zu absolvieren hatte einziges
thema wie können die bürgerinnen und
bürger entlastet werden angesichts der
rasant steigenden energiepreise
am ende kam ein klassischer kompromiss
heraus manche kommentatoren finden einer
mit der staatlichen gießkanne andere
sehen darin einiges für jetzt und vieles
für morgen die wichtigsten details fasst
bernd weltin zusammen
ortstermin in einer studenten wg in
soeben ist energieberaterin der
verbraucherzentrale
und kann sich vor anfragen kaum retten
es geht um jede kilowattstunde um jeden
versteckten energiefresser
also wenn ich außerhalb der höhere die
mir sagen sie haben bisher 150 euro
gezahlt sollen zukünftig 500 bis 600
euro monatlich zahlen dann ist natürlich
die sorge groß wo soll das noch
hinführen
seit wochen ringt die regierung um einen
entlastungs plan jetzt hat sie die
vergangenen nacht durchverhandelt quasi
im merkels stil also genau so wie es
eigentlich nicht mehr laufen sollte
heute vormittag dann die verkündung das
paket steht wir haben es uns in dieser
nacht nicht leicht gemacht es hat auch
etwas zeit gebraucht die
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen zu bewerten
und dann zu einem paket zu verbinden
aber es ist gelungen das ziel dieser
ampel koalition ist es den sozialen
zusammenhalt den zusammenhalt als
gesellschaft die stabilität in dieser
gesellschaft in diesen zeiten in zeiten
der wende auch zu stärken wir müssen
handeln und deshalb handeln wir als amt
und wir haben dabei wie breite der
gesellschaft im blick und das wurde
beschlossen ein einmaliger energie
zuschuss von 300 euro brutto ausgezahlt
mit dem gehalt für familien eine
einmalzahlung von 100 euro pro kind und
100 euro zuschuss für die empfänger von
sozialleistungen
in den kommenden 90 tagen sollen
monatstickets im nahverkehr nur neun
euro kosten die fdp idee vom tank rabatt
ist vom tisch stattdessen wird die
energie steuern auf kraftstoffe gesenkt
benzin soll so 30 cent diesel 14 cent
billiger werden alle maßnahmen die
direkt versuchen den benzinpreis zu
reduzieren sei es ein tank rabatt wo
staatliche subventionen gezahlt worden
wären sei es jetzt temporäre
steuersenkungen sind aus meiner sicht
nicht der richtige weg denn wir müssen
einfach akzeptieren dass wir durch putin
durch den konflikt den wir da haben es
mit steigenden energiepreisen zu tun
haben auch die müssen wir mit energie
sparen reagieren die opposition
kritisiert hier würde geld mit der
gießkanne verteilt und auch die
wirtschaft brauche dringend eigene
entlastung es ist sozial
unausgewogen war als
bundestagsabgeordneter erhalte ich
genauso viel wie die alleinerziehende
mutter das ist ein problem wir sind der
auffassung dass es richtig ist bürger zu
entlasten da müsste mehr getan werden es
aber auch notwendig ist betriebe zu
entlasten nehmen sie eine bäckerei mit
einem hohen energiebedarf da vielen
antworten
[Musik]
energieberaterin eben plagt noch eine
andere sorge einige gruppen die sie oft
gerät wie studenten und rentner können
vom paket kauf profitieren
ein bundespolitisches beben ist nicht zu
erwarten am kommenden sonntag aber auch
von einer landtagswahl im saarland
können trends ausgehen beim letzten mal
2017 war das so damals für die cdu die
damals überraschend deutlich in
saarbrücken gewann diesmal könnte es
umgekehrt sein dass ganz aktuelle zdf
politbarometer zeigt für das saarland
dieses bild wenn schon heute
landtagswahl wäre dann käme die cdu auf
28 prozent die spd auf 41 die linke wäre
mit 4 prozent nicht im parlament die afg
käme auf 6,5 prozent die grünen auf 5,5
und die fdp auf 5 prozent
und dann haben wir noch gefragt wen sich
die menschen als ministerpräsidentin
oder ministerpräsidenten wünschen nur 30
prozent sagen amtsinhaber tobias hans
von der cdu aber 57 prozent
herausforderin anke rehlinger von der
spd da könnte sich also einen
regierungswechsel andeuten mehr außer
brücken von susanne freitag
bürgernähe aus dem tablet das ist ruby
tobi von zuhause steuert der korona
positive tobias ans seinen roboter
wahlkampf-endspurt 4.0 er setzt trotz
allem weiter auf sieg und will die groko
wollen die wahl gewinnen auch damit das
wir versprechen dass wir der spd eine
einladung versenden diese gute arbeit
weiterzuführen nur der cdu wählt bekommt
am ende auch nur grob wer spd wählt kann
unterstützen ampel aufwachen die
umfragen sehen sie klar vorne anke
rehlinger hat sympathien für die gruppo
bekundet beklagt aber dass ihr die info
viele wie sich die cdu als juniorpartner
aufstellen würde eine cdu die dann wird
über 20 jahren zum ersten mal wieder
verloren hat muss natürlich auch erstmal
beweis dafür antreten dass sie für
stabile verhältnisse steht
und ich muss auch wissen mit wem am ende
habe ich dann zu reden wenn es denn um
regierungsbildungen geht
alternativen zur großen koalition sind
schwierig wohl auch deshalb schickte
berlin viel personal an dieser die
grünen müssen jetzt beweisen dass sie
ihren streit dauerhaft im griff die fdp
muss nach zehn jahren abwesenheit zeigen
dass sie regierungsfähig personal hat
die afg hat nicht mal einen
spitzenkandidaten drei kreis kandidaten
treten an zwei von ihnen droht wegen
parteiinterner streitigkeiten der
parteiausschuss
und die linke könnte nach oskar
lafontaines austritt aus dem landtag
fliegen entsprechend hoch auch hier die
berliner promi dichte für alle kleinen
parteien sind die fünf prozent wirklich
eine hürde den meisten berliner
rückenwind hatte anke rehlinger lars
klingbeil der wind kühnert und sogar der
kanzler die wahl hat symbolkraft für den
bund das zeigt auf jeden fall dass das
was olaf scholz gesagt hat dass die
bundestagswahl sicherlich ein großer
erfolg war aber dass es eigentlich darum
geht ein jahrzehnt der sozialdemokratie
jetzt zu starten bei tobias hans war die
bundes-cdu einmal da vor drei wochen als
der vorstand tagte seitdem war niemand
mehr im saarland wir haben die große
bundestrainer eingeflogen weder zu
aschermittwochstreffen noch zur anderen
veranstaltungen von daher machen wir das
eben so wie wir sind aus eigener stärke
lässt die partei ihren kandidaten allein
sollte es so sein dass im
konrad-adenauer-haus sich nach den
umfragen die erkenntnis durchgesetzt hat
dieser kampf ist bereits verloren wird
man auch kein bundesvorsitzenden mehr
auf einen verlorenen posten schicken
tobias hans will robbie tobi morgen
gerne wieder selbst ersetzen denn bei
diesem endspurt geht es um viel für ihn
und für die cdu
russisches erdgas soll es in zukunft nur
noch gegen rubel geben dass es die
forderung von wladimir putin die gestern
nicht nur politiker verbraucher und
unternehmen sondern sichtbar auch die
märkte aufgeschreckt hat jetzt einen tag
danach gibt es erste reaktionen von
unterschiedlichen ländern valerie haller
wir sehen die genau aus entrüstung und
ablehnung auf breiter front ich glaube
so kann man zusammenfassen nach jetzigen
stand will sich der westen nicht
erpressen lassen und verweist auch auf
die verträge in welchen dollar oder euro
eben als zahlungsmittel festgelegt sind
würde das gas mit rubel tatsächlich
bezahlt könnte das den westen zwingen
womöglich die eigenen sanktionen zu
umgehen der rubel müsste vermutlich von
der russischen zentralbank bereit
gestellt werden mit der der westen keine
geschäfte machen will das möchte man
natürlich eigentlich vermeiden die frage
ist wie reagiert putin auf einen rubel
boykott er könnte den gashahn zudrehen
ungefähr eine woche noch dann will putin
seinen plan umsetzen eines hat er mit
seiner ankündigung aber jetzt schon
erreicht der seit dem krieg schwer
gebeutelte rubel ist heute wieder stark
gestiegen und hat der bundesverband der
energie und wasserwirtschaft die
bundesregierung aufgefordert die frühe
warnstufe im nationalen notfallplan gas
auszurufen was bedeutet das genau das
würde bedeuten dass die zuständigen
länder beauftragten und die
bundesnetzagentur ihre
krisenkommunikation sozusagen
intensivieren müssten dass die behörden
notfall abläufe konkret planen das wäre
die erste von drei krisen stufen in der
letzten würde die bundesnetzagentur
entscheiden wer noch gas bekommt und wer
nicht haushaltskunden jedenfalls müssen
sich keine sorgen machen ihre versorgung
hat per gesetz vorrang er wird im
extremfall der industrie der hahn
zugedreht
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt
der bundesrechnungshof hat der satz
größe kritik an der bisherigen
klimaschutzpolitik geäußert und fordert
eine neuausrichtung in einem
sondergutachten heißt es dass
milliardenbeträge für nicht wirksame
programme ausgegeben würden auch die
steuerung und koordinierung sei
mangelhaft der rechnungshof warnt dass
die klimaschutz ziele für das jahr 2030
mit den bisherigen maßnahmen verfehlt
werden dürften
bevor im april das welt pressefoto des
jahres gekürt wird wurden jetzt bereits
und zum allerersten mal überhaupt
regionale gewinner bestimmt
ausgezeichnet wurden 24 fotografinnen
und fotografen darunter dieses bild der
verheerenden waldbrände in griechenland
im august 2021 aufgenommen hat des
constantinus tsakalidis für asien gewann
die aufnahme des fotografen brand jansen
die zeigt einen kinobesitzer in kabul
der nach der machtübernahme der taliban
schließen musste
lotta bilder die man so schnell nicht
mehr vergisst wir haben heute viele
wichtige menschen gesehen die in
wichtigen konferenzen über das schicksal
der ukraine debattierten gucken wir zum
ende der sendung auf die die all das
ganz besonders betrifft die jetzt nicht
nur sicherheit brauchen sondern eine
perspektive
die eu hat leitlinien beschlossen damit
ukraine flüchtlinge möglichst gut
aufgenommen werden ganz zentral dabei
schule für die kinder und zwar möglichst
schnell das sei ein hauptfaktor bei der
rückkehr zur stabilität schreibt die eu
jetzt sind leitlinien dass eine deren
konkrete umsetzung vor ort etwas anderes
und wenn man bedenkt dass die zahl von
ukrainischen kindern auf der flucht die
ein recht haben auf schule in die
millionen geht dann kann man die
herausforderung erahnen dort ferber
zeigt sie am beispiel düsseldorf
in der betreuungs klasse dieser
düsseldorfer grundschule lernt martha
jetzt deutsch gemeinsam mit elf anderen
kindern aus der ukraine
unterricht erst mal auf russisch das
verstehen alle es ist ein anfang es ist
auch ablenkung vom erlebten
ich habe schon neue freunde gefunden und
es ist immer sehr lustig hier
eine russischsprachige
grundschullehrerin dass es zufall und
glück in diesem tag alexandra timo war
unterrichtet jetzt alle kinder zwischen
fünf und neun jahren aus der ukraine am
wichtigsten einfach loslegen was es hier
gleich dass die kinder gar kein wort
deutsch konnten und hier müssen wir
anfangen und die kinder die haben
riesige interesse die hohlen schulamtes
schule diesen schon bereit jeden tag
bekommt der schulleiter neue anmeldungen
von ukrainischen familien so viele dass
er nicht alle aufnehmen kann er selbst
sucht dann andere grundschulen für die
kinder und er findet sie auch
ich glaube im moment ist es noch so dass
die hilfsbereitschaft weiter andauern
wird aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen
das ist in einer gewissen zeit dann auch
so ist dass es zu viel wird und das dann
noch manche sagen jetzt kann ich nicht
mehr oder jetzt reicht's kinder
zusätzlichen klassen aufnehmen das geht
nicht überall schulen fehlt es an platz
es fehlt an lehrkräften und nun kommen
viele neue schülerinnen und schüler
hinzu
es ist für alle jetzt nochmal nach
corona eine große herausforderung und
natürlich es steht und fällt auch mit
zusätzlichem personal das wissen wir so
viel braucht keine zusätzliche lehrerin
die achtjährige nimmt einfach weiter am
unterricht ihrer grundschule in odessa
teil online aus ihrer
flüchtlingsunterkunft in köln
digitales lernen ist in der ukraine eine
selbstverständlichkeit das hilft jetzt
wir versuchen den menschen auch die
digitale angebote zu vermieten die zu
dieser zeit in der ukraine bestehen
damit sie die verbindungen zu sprache zu
kultur zu zur geschichte nicht verlieren
wie viele kinder kommen wie lange sie
bleiben völlig unklar was gerade zu tun
ist ist vermag aber klar deutsch lernen
sie kennt jetzt die farben
digitales lernen ist in der ukraine eine
selbstverständlichkeit man lernt nie aus
das war unsere welt an diesem donnerstag
krieg in der ukraine tut der westen
genug das ist das thema gleich bei der
kollegin marietta slomka ausnahmsweise
mal nach dem heute journal wir wünschen
ihnen jetzt noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]
guten abend da hatte sich doch in der
vergangenen nacht tatsächlich hier in
schleswig-holstein mal ein kleines
wolken fällt gebildet aber schon am
vormittag war das innerhalb von wenigen
stunden komplett aufgelöst und dann gab
es wieder strahlenden sonnenschein im
ergebnis gab es dann bis zu 22 grad an
der donau es ist in diesen es einfach
viel zu trocken häufig sind nur so 0 bis
etwa 10 liter regen pro quadratmeter
gefallen nur hier in der bitte da gab es
mal einen tag da hat es mal etwas
kräftiger geregnet das ist höchstens
zehn prozent dessen was man
üblicherweise erwarten kann und hier in
der mitte waren es so maximal ein
viertel dessen es braucht also unbedingt
regen aber der ist derzeit nicht in
sicht was in sicht ist das sind die
nachttemperaturen sinken hier in der
osthälfte auf 0 bis minus 3 grad an der
ostsee und ganz im westen bleibt es bei
sechs bis null grad milder es bleibt
wieder klar in der nacht doch morgen
strahlt die sonne es gibt höchstens mal
harmlose quellwolken der wind dazu kommt
aus westlichen bis nordwestlichen
richtungen ist aber eigentlich nur an
der küste spürbar so liegen die
höchsttemperaturen hier an der nordsee
über 13 bis 15 sonst bei 14 bis 18 grad
und richtung südwesten geht's auf 19 bis
20 grad auf in der nächsten woche ist
das hier die wetterlage und daran sehen
sie das ist von norden tatsächlich noch
mal kälter wird ob dann ein bisschen
regen fällt oder sogar nochmal eine
schneeflocke ist noch überhaupt nicht
ausgemacht dass es aber von norden
kälter wird das sehen sie hier schon und
es wird noch etwas wolkiger guten abend